in some sense there is no Theory of  Everything  right any formal system that is Rich  enough to model the axiom's arithmetic  is is either inconsistent or incomplete  and we call it girdles in completeness  theorem because we don't take the  inconsistency thing too seriously so  that means no matter what  scientific theory we have  it's not the final word there'll always  be if the if the theory is Rich enough  to do arithmetic and most scientific  theories are they wouldn't be taken  seriously so they're rich enough to do  arithmetic so they're rich enough to  have a girdle statement that that is  outside their scope and yet is true  um but not provable within that theory